Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Stefania Betti
Vi racconto perché, in Belgio,
ho deciso di cercare
le madri dei miei rapitori.
Sei anni fa sono stata
sequestrata in Siria,
mentre lavoravo con una troupe della RAI.
E durante questo sequestro,
ho avuto modo di riconoscere
il gruppo che ci aveva arrestato,
questo gruppo di cui
avevo già parlato nei miei servizi.
Aveva un nome, Jabhat al-Nusra,
che significa "Fronte
di liberazione del popolo".
Poi si sono sciolti nell'ISIS;
ma durante le prime ore del mio sequestro
ho pensato a questo nome:
Jabhat al-Nusra, "Fronte
di liberazione del popolo".
Liberazione, già: ma da che cosa?
Forse, liberazione dalla libertà.
Almeno, questo è quello
che ho sperimentato io,
durante la mia prigionia.
Sono stata tenuta in isolamento,
coperta - letteralmente, coperta -
da una coperta, perché non avevo un burqa.
Quindi dovevo essere relegata lì.
Ma non ero sola:
ero in isolamento, ma non ero sola.
C'erano i miliziani armati,
che mi vigilavano giorno e notte.
Erano uomini -
sono stata anche con una donna,
la mia carceriera -
e ho imparato poi a distinguerli
in base alle lingue
che parlavano e ai dialetti.
Ma chi erano questi miliziani?
Alcuni erano francofoni:
questo significa che potevano venire
tanto dalla Tunisia,
quanto dalla Francia o dal Belgio.
Così, quando nel 2018
mi sono trasferita a Bruxelles,
ho pensato che era arrivato
il momento di andare a scoprire
chi erano le madri
di questi "Foreign fighters".
Un dialogo, un incontro
che per me significava moltissimo:
significava, innanzitutto, riconciliarmi
con quell'esperienza tremenda
che è stata per me
la privazione della libertà;
ma è stato anche poi scoprire, capire,
se è giusto o è sbagliato
attribuire alle madri, sempre,
l'origine di tutte le colpe.
Ho incontrato due donne:
la prima si chiama Saliha Ben Ali,
ed è una donna estremamente forte
che ama il Belgio
perché le ha permesso di crescere
in una cultura libera, e non patriarcale.
E ama le sue leggi,
ama la libertà di espressione
e la differenza, la tolleranza.
Tutti questi sono principi
che lei ha assorbito,
e poi ha trasmesso al figlio.
Io ho letto la sua biografia,
e ho avuto l'impressione
di essere ritornata al liceo,
quando leggevo le tragedie greche.
Lei sembra l'eroe di una tragedia greca:
cerca di ribellarsi
a un destino inesorabile,
a un fato maligno,
perché fa tutto giusto...
e poi diventa tutto sbagliato,
tutte le scelte che lei fa.
Con questo figlio, Sabri, che a 18 anni,
dopo aver ricevuto
il lavaggio del cervello
da una organizzazione
apparentemente di beneficenza,
che si chiamava "Sharia for Belgium",
decide di partire.
Ovviamente, non è una decisione così,
che è avvenuta da un giorno alla notte.
Ci sono stati mesi di radicalizzazione
in cui lei stava vicino
al figlio, per monitorarlo;
ma poi, la decisione che sì,
è avvenuta dal giorno alla notte
è stata quella di partire,
perché a un certo punto Sabri
è stato così intelligente
da dissimulare,
far credere alla mamma
che s'era rinsavito.
Quindi lei ha mollato la presa.
Era addirittura arrivata al punto
di non permettergli più di uscire di casa;
ma poi, quando ha visto
che il figlio si era rinsavito,
dopo una bellissima vacanza
trascorsa insieme,
in Marocco sulle spiagge,
a fare cose che, nella sua nuova visione
dell'Islam proibitivo, erano peccato,
ha pensato: mio figlio ha 18 anni,
può sbagliare e può cambiare idea.
In fondo, chi è mio figlio?
È quel bambino giocherellone
che mi tirava la gonna?
È quel bambino che a basket
proteggeva i bambini più deboli dai bulli?
Questo è mio figlio,
e questo è tornato mio figlio.
Una mattina si sveglia,
e trova la stanza di Sabri vuota.
Capisce immediatamente
quello che è successo,
chiama la polizia per farlo arrestare.
Ma la polizia non arresta
un diciottenne che viaggia da solo.
È libero.
Anche se questo diciottenne,
fino al giorno prima,
non sapeva rifarsi il letto.
Però è un neo maggiorenne.
Saliha ha vissuto questa grande tragedia.
Ma non è rimasta passiva:
ha fondato un'associazione
che si chiama "Save Belgium".
E già dal nome fa capire
che non solo vuole aiutare
le famiglie che si trovano
nella sua stessa condizione,
ma vuole salvare una generazione
di nuovi potenziali foreign fighters.
Nella sua stessa condizione
si è trovata un'altra donna,
che si chiama Fatiha.
Questa donna non è solo madre
di foreign fighters;
è nonna di bambini innocenti.
Bambini innocenti che si trovano
nel campo di Al-Hol.
È un campo di detenzione
in una parte molto desertica della Siria,
al confine con l'Iraq.
Ed è un campo molto discusso,
perché ci si trovano
le vedove del Daesh,
dell'ISIS.
Si spera - o quantomeno, gli Stati Uniti
stanno esortando le forze locali
a liberare questo campo;
ma le cancellerie europee
hanno l'obbligo di riprendersi
i loro cittadini,
ovvero i foreign fighters.
La maggior parte di questi
sono donne e sono bambini.
Che colpa hanno, questi bambini?
Quando ho parlato con Fatiha,
che mi ha fatto vedere
le foto di questi bambini
che hanno un'età compresa
tra l'uno e i sei anni -
alcuni sono biondi,
perché la moglie di suo figlio
è una ragazza delle Fiandre
che si è convertita;
altri invece sono di carnagione olivastra,
perché poi sia sua figlia che la nuora
si sono dovute risposare,
quindi lì i matrimoni
vengono combinati all'ultimo minuto -
ecco, ho visto questo insieme di bambini,
e ho pensato che sono degli innocenti.
E che meritano di tornare
in Belgio, dalla nonna.
Fatiha ha espresso il suo cordoglio,
davanti all'immagine del figlio morto,
nel computer.
Ho riflettuto sull'assurdità
di un lutto solo digitale.
Mentirei se vi dicessi
che ho provato compassione
per la foto di quel ragazzo morto,
per quel ragazzo morto:
aveva i capelli spettinati,
le labbra violacee,
una ferita pulita all'altezza del cuore;
e io non ho provato nulla,
perché poteva essere
uno dei miei rapitori.
Però mentirei se vi dicessi
che non ho provato compassione
per quella donna che piangeva.
E mentirei se vi dicessi
che non mi sta a cuore il destino
dei figli di quel Nureddin,
quel ragazzo che ha fatto
la Jihad, e che è morto.
Ora sono passati sei anni,
da quell esperienza;
sono diventata madre.
E ragiono in modo diverso.
Però già all'epoca,
prima di sperimentare
la maternità biologica,
avevo già capito
che parte, almeno buona parte
delle madri di quei foreign fighters
non se la stavano passando bene.
Forse stavano vivendo la stessa angoscia
che viveva la mia, di madre,
sapendo che ero in un paese in guerra.
Come è cambiata la mia vita?
Innanzitutto,
provo un grandissimo senso di gratitudine
per ogni giorno che passa: è come un dono.
Non credo di avere dei traumi:
ma provo un profondo bisogno di capire
qual è il comportamento
dietro la devianza,
cioè che cosa spinge una persona
a violare i diritti umani
di un'altra persona.
Ecco, questo mi fa arrabbiare.
E non avviene solo da parte dei criminali,
quelli che noi chiamiamo terroristi:
avviene tutti i giorni.
Quindi io mi arrabbio
davanti alle violazioni dei diritti umani
dei migranti, dei minori non accompagnati;
e delle persone che vengono private
della libertà di espressione,
come è capitato a me.
Ecco: io, nel mio piccolo,
cosa posso fare?
Posso parlarne,
perché sono una giornalista,
e quindi lo sto facendo qui con voi.
Perché sento il desiderio di aiutare,
così come sono stata aiutata io,
ad uscire fuori da quella caverna oscura
che sarebbe potuta diventare la mia vita
se fossi rimasta
nelle mani dei miei rapitori.
Grazie.
(Applausi)